[Music]
we brought together seven people who are
parents
i'm a parent i'm a parent i'm a parent
i'm a parent i'm a parent i am a parent
and i am the parent one of them is a
liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
the survivors win a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the prize
can the group find the odd man out
right now my strategy for this game is i
actually wrote down some very specific
questions
all i know is i'm not trying to get
voted out the first round
so i'm looking to bond with these other
parents i think i'm a really good judge
of
uh who's a parent and who's not i have
no game plan going into this
i'm gonna do my best i have no idea what
i'm doing all right we're about to start
oh i'm nervous and the time
starts now oh wow i don't know what
you're supposed to do in these first
three minutes
it's it's pretty crazy
oh hi everyone
i am a dad wow this is like rapid fire
45 uh i'm 43
and oh my god it is chaotic
okay i guess this video is kind of gonna
be my uh
i have a two years old daughter
my reveal okay
okay i'm 29 and a dad 24
mom um
i remember his
first poop
[Music]
oh i'm the worst typer they're gonna
think i'm the mole just because i suck
at keeping
oh my goodness everyone i'm 37 i'm
expecting
this number oh
just started to get used to
a lot of videos of my friends oh no
cliff you haven't told anyone yet oh no
okay
which is true like and he he sits still
for it for the very first time which is
incredible
uh before he would just skip all these
videos videos videos
videos videos it'll drive me insane
i feel like so much of this is just
trying to prove that you're
not the one as opposed to sniffing
someone out
but i don't know
wait how old is everyone's kid
my oldest toy is three
no idea i have no idea
[Music]
my house is like a kindergarten
i don't know johnny that seems suss is
that how the kids say
suss
[Music]
10 and 19 holy crap this is going so
fast
crystal's favorite toy story character
does that matter
[Music]
i feel like i should have a notepad
who's
who who's doing what who's single people
are talking about they're single
i don't know
i just feel good i don't feel good about
that round i felt great about the round
i'm a little suspicious i'm not really
sure who to vote for
i kind of want to vote for it denisha
like her responses were very
short i think i'm gonna have to go with
denisha i'm so sorry
denisha actually said that i'm
definitely a parent
i think everyone saw that crystal i'm so
sorry but
i'm probably going to vote for you for
this round because you say my favorite
character
of toy story is bull peep
probably johnny i can tell you all about
being a parent
same like what
i am going to vote for johnny this round
uh
mostly because johnny said i can tell
you anything about being a parent and
like
i don't know that blatant statement and
cockiness
i'm gonna vote for crystal and that's
probably what that's probably what
single people are doing non-parents is
they're thinking about themselves and
not their kids janisha
janisha just has my my vote for this one
is the mole
um she spaced her kids out really far
i have no idea who i'm voting for in
this round i know it's not johnny or
i think daniel so we'll see what happens
i tallied the votes and it came out to
a three-way tie what the hell
that's insane and the three-way tie
was between denisha johnny
and crystal oh
[Music]
[Music]
why was i voted out
i don't know i have a gut feeling about
johnny and i think i need to stick with
my vote
i gotta stick with my gut and go crystal
because
people that are parents instinctively
say what their kid likes not what they
like i think
i think it's crystal because i go
with my gut send
votes are in and the person who is
eliminated in our first round is crystal
sorry i should have said that my
daughter
liked bo peep not that i liked bo peep
though it's true i do she's great
for this round tell a brief story about
you and your child
and a time they overwhelmed you it was
probably nearing the end of my second
pregnancy when i was like nine months
he's he was two at the time and he
decided that he wanted to clog our
toilet
so he just pooped in the toilet stuffed
a whole bunch of
toilet paper in the thing flooded that i
walk out
he's covered in water i feel like that's
really gross um my
kid just gets hyped all of a sudden he's
three puts his hands on the wall and
starts twerking
and then the one-year-old copies what my
kid is doing i was like
where did you learn that from and my
wife and i always
point fingers at each other that's
definitely you okay hi everyone
so real quick my when my daughter was
born she had a very loud voice
so every single night she screams so
loud for hours
that she doesn't want to go to sleep and
we even tried to put in earbuds
and we were like hold on a second let me
try this
there's no difference she's so loud that
we can never sleep
whenever i do my makeup i let my
daughter use like a lip gloss this one
time
she took one of the expensive lipsticks
that i have
and she colored her whole face with it
her whole face and it was a matte
lipstick
so it was so hard to get off i was
teaching
my son how to snowboard and we ski down
into the line and he shouts out with
no reason or no rhyme daddy i'm gonna
marry a man
and everybody in the crowd heard it and
looks at me
and i'm like good for you
bud whoever you want to marry is who you
want to marry
that's my story
um gosh i can't think of a story i guess
i'll tell you about the story with my 19
year old
a few months ago he got frustrated with
me
and he tried to commit suicide right in
front of me
um it was really scary
and we couldn't call i was at work we
couldn't call 9-1-1 because it was
during a time where
we thought maybe a cop would shoot him
if they went to my house
and i didn't know what to do so
um it was probably the worst day or
worst time of my life i
i was really scared and i don't know if
any other parents got
have have experienced this but it's the
worst feeling you could ever feel and
even feeling it now makes me want to cry
thank you for sharing denisha
it was nice getting to see everybody i
have no idea after that round
when everybody else was talking i
thought it was funny and cute but
when it came to my part it was just
really hard denisha's story
oh my goodness that was one of the most
harrowing things i've heard in a really
long time
i think i'm gonna go johnny here just
because there was some heat on johnny
from the last
from the last vote i will probably vote
for daniel
just because of the lack of details and
the lack of description
i might just stick with my gut on
denisha
i'm sorry denisha um johnny seemed
like he was telling more of a generic
story i think i'm going to have to go
with johnny
i really feel like you should be the one
to raise your kid instead of hiring
people to raise your kid
i'm going to put johnny again boy pick
up your girl like what
the second person eliminated from the
game
is johnny oh my god
i'm sorry johnny ah i guess
i really don't look like a parent i
should have dressed
in like a polo shirt that sucks
[Music]
you will have four minutes to talk to
each other
and the time starts now who is the one
who said um i don't know what to do with
a three plus year old
that's me okay so my oldest is a
three-year-old from
um in july july 6 and uh she just loves
a lot of marvel
like on disney plus there's like a whole
bunch of marvel stuff that you can watch
um i don't know who was the one too no
screen time was that johnny did we we
already voted him off right yeah
um that's right that's why we voted him
off
how old are you i'm 24. you're a young
mom too
okay so i had my first um i was 20 and i
turned 21
when i had him wow good for you guys
i don't know how you do it as a that
young because i was 36 7
8 when it all happened and it just it's
a very different feeling dude i don't
know how you guys do i feel like i'm
tired all the time
like oh yeah i love it i love it
i think it's just because like since
we're young we have a lot of energy
yeah exactly i'm a very creative it's
absolutely true
what time do your kids go to bed like do
you guys have a bedtime for your kids
bedtime routine seven o'clock in the
bath seven thirty he's in the bed and my
life
starts at eight o'clock what's the
oldest out of all you guys
cause i think i have the oldest i think
you just i think you have the oldest
okay i have a 10 and 19. i actually
thought we voted
voted them all out i just want to hear
more from you
is your kid in daycare or have any of
you guys had your kids in daycare
yeah so my kids in daycare uh my wife's
a physician
and i i work full-time so like if
he wasn't in daycare he would take all
my energy like just
all every second of myself just to
entertain him so there's no way we could
do both and we're just
like so grateful that our daycare is
staying open with the small amount of
kids and like every parent is just
trying to be careful
i used to work at a daycare but now i'm
a stay-at-home mom
so like since i've had not that there's
anything wrong with daycares but since
i've been there
it's like i kind of know like what goes
on i just rather would spend time with
her at home
because daycare is expensive very
expensive
i'm just struggling with what we're
going to do with this distant learning
or high degree learning but that that's
when that one's coming oh yeah
our school districts have already
emailed us that we're doing in-home
learning i was just doing a hybrid uh at
a certain point starting off with
distant learning but then they're going
to go into a hybrid
if we elect to
everybody's really good everybody's
convincing they've got their story down
i am the youngest i'm the younger i'm
the youngest one on here
so hopefully they all like have that
mentality like yo
she's not the mole i think it was daniel
dre and emily that
i was kind of concerned about but cliff
seems like he's definitely a parent
daniel gosh it's almost daniel and emily
because emily was talking too much
i think i am going to
go with daniel i wanted
more out of him and i wonder
if he is just a sophisticated
man that knows the ropes of
parenting does that make sense
i feel like cliff was right when he said
that we
we thought the mole was out but we just
wanted to talk but if i had to choose
someone it'd probably
be emily i don't know who i'm gonna go
with i might go with
daniel and michael cliff i'm gonna go
with daniel
the result of the last round was
we had another tie the tie is between
daniel and emily so what we're gonna
actually
do for this round is we're gonna have
each person gets 30 seconds to state
their case
daniel you go first all right did i get
this right
you should believe me because i have the
open adoption certificate to prove it i
have
the divorce financial bills to prove
that i fought for custody
um because i have the smartest little
monkey trying to make his little
minecraft
world on his youtube channel and
it's a delight uh i have all of the poop
stories we tried to do
uh elimination communication early on he
was actually
potty trained by nine months which
worked until about one year
and then it went all to waste um
pun intended i have bad jokes galore i'm
definitely
a dad all right four three two one
and your time starts now okay y'all so
daniel said that he got proof wait it
doesn't got proof to show down right now
but i do
i'm twenty do the matthew i'm 20. my
daughter's two right
and i have this tattoo right here it
says 10 19
17. she's going for the tattoo it's her
birthday why would i
just have this random tattoo oh my god
she didn't do the math it's her birthday
22. that's the best proof that i can
show y'all right now
is the proof that's on my body um i love
you danielle you're so sweet
but i'm a little bit i'm coming i'm
coming for you
emily she's using a tattoo to prove her
case but i feel like that could have
been like
a boyfriend a girlfriend you don't know
girl
i'm sorry i'm sorry
what do we do here what do i do daniel's
a good guy
i'm a nice person
very close votes but the next person
eliminated is emily
oh my god guys so i just got eliminated
and i had a feeling i wasn't gonna make
it to the last round if you really think
about it when you think of parents
i feel like people wouldn't put me in
that category unless you see my child
um standing next to me and even then my
daughter doesn't really look like me
because she's mixed
so even then people would still think
that i
am not a parent
[Music]
if the majority decides they've already
caught the mole they can go ahead and
end the game
but if the majority feels they haven't
caught them all and they want to keep
going
they can't continue the game
[Music]
i thought this was going to be a lot
easier
why would they want to continue we
should end the game i really think that
emily was a parent so cliff denisha
and dre said end the game and daniel
said
continue if the image i show you
is green you've caught the mole and you
won
and if the image is red the mole is
still in the game
and you've lost which means i won
because i voted to keep going
all right here we go
three two one
[Music]
oh he won what's it mean yes you won
i'm gonna have the mole reveal
themselves when i count down to one the
mole can raise their hand and reveal him
or herself
three two one go ahead
and raise your hand
wait wait here's what's funny this is
the first time i'm seeing crystal
right thank you
and i just couldn't keep up like i had
answers to everything i have a lovely
three and a half year old niece
yeah beautiful i just i just can't type
it's really easy to talk to other
parents it really is especially when
you're in a room together
and you have to it was just nice seeing
other people from a different
perspective it was a lot of fun it was
fun to meet to
people and have a fun little game and
diversion in this crazy coveted times
i think the important reminder we always
should have is to not judge a book by
its cover
i definitely wish that i could have
learned more from the parents on here
because
one day maybe i will be a parent in some
capacity
and i would have loved to have
heard their honest experiences time is
so valuable so
spend it as best you can with the kids
that you have around you
everyone can be a parent but be a good
one
don't raise no apples we don't need any
more of those
what defines a good parent i think it's
definitely oh my goodness this
is the struggle of a parent they never
leave
all right well there's nothing else to
add this has been a fun and great
experience
say bye bye bye